I'd like to introduce you to an
interesting person named let's see he
lives in Italy at the South Tirol Museum
of Archaeology because he's a mummy this
is an artist rendition of what he might
have looked like when he was alive fifty
three hundred years ago you want to see
what he looks like today okay brace
yourselves
gross mummy pick coming at you so he's
not as handsome as he used to be but
he's actually in great shape for a mummy
because he was discovered frozen in ice
let's see is the oldest mummy that's
been discovered with preserved skin
fifty three hundred years is super old
older than the Egyptian pyramids and it
sees skin is covered in 61 black tattoos
all lines and crosses on parts of his
body where he might have experienced
pain so scientists think that they might
have been used to mark sites for some
kind of therapy like acupuncture so
clearly if the oldest skin we've seen is
all tattooed up tattooing is a very
ancient practice but fast-forward to
today and tattoos are everywhere almost
one in four Americans has a tattoo it's
a multi-billion dollar industry and
whether you love tattoos or hate them
this talk will change the way you think
about them so why are tattoos so popular
unlike let's see most of us today use
tattoos for some kind of self-expression
personally I love tattoos because I love
art and there's something so wonderful
to me almost romantic about the way a
tattoo as an art form cannot be
commodified right your tattoo lives and
dies with you it can't be bought or sold
or traded so it's only value is really
personal to you and I love that now I
tend to gravitate towards really
colorful tattoos because I'm obsessed
with color I teach a whole course on it
at my university but my very first
tattoo was an all black tattoo like
let's eat
yep I did that cliche thing that young
people do sometimes and I got a tattoo
in a language I can't even read okay but
I was 19 years old I had just returned
from my first trip overseas I was in
Japan in the mountains meditating in
Buddhist monasteries and it was a really
meaningful experience to me so I wanted
to commemorate it with this Japanese and
Chinese character for mountain now here
is what blows my mind my 14 year old
tattoo and it sees fifty three hundred
year old tattoos are made of the same
exact stuff soot that black powdery
carbon dust that gets left behind in the
fireplace when you burn stuff and if you
zoom way way in on either my tattoo or
it's these tattoos you'll find that they
all look something like this a tattoo is
nothing more than a bunch of tiny
pigment particles soot in this case they
get trapped in the dermis which is the
layer of tissue right underneath the
surface of the skin so in over 5,000
years we've done very little to update
tattoo technology apart from getting
access to more colors and slightly more
efficient methods of installation while
I'm an artist I'm also a scientist and I
direct a laboratory that researches
nanotechnology which is the science of
building things with ultra tiny building
blocks thousands of times smaller even
than the width of a human hair and I
began to ask myself how could
nanotechnology serve tattooing if
tattoos are just a bunch of particles in
the skin could we swap those particles
out for ones that do something more
interesting here's my big idea I believe
that tattoos can give you superpowers
now I don't mean they're gonna make us
fly but I do think that we can have
superpowers in the sense the tattoos can
give us new abilities that we don't
currently possess by upgrading the
particles we can engineer tattoo inks
that will change not only the appearance
of our skin but also the function of our
skin let me show you this is a diagram
of a micro capsule
it's a tiny hollow particle with a
protective outer shell about the size of
a tattoo pigment and you can fill the
inside with practically whatever you
want so what if we put interesting
materials inside of these microcapsules
and made tattooing with them what sorts
of things could we make a tattoo do what
problems could we solve what human
limitations could we overcome well
here's one idea one of our weaknesses as
humans is that we can't see ultraviolet
or UV light
that's the high-energy part of sunlight
that causes sunburn and increases our
risk of skin cancer many animals and
insects can actually see UV light but we
can't if we could we'd be able to see
sunscreen when it's applied on our skin
unfortunately most of us don't wear
sunscreen and those of us who do can't
really tell when it wears off because
it's invisible it's the main reason we
treat over five million cases of
preventable skin cancer every year in
the US alone costing our economy over
five billion dollars annually so how
could we overcome this human weakness
with a tattoo well if the problem is
that we can't see UV rays maybe we could
make a tattoo detect them for us so I
thought why don't we take some
microcapsules load it up with a UV
sensitive color-changing dye and make a
tattoo ink out of that now one of the
troubles of being a tattoo technologist
is finding willing test subjects and
when it came time to test this tattoo
ink I thought it best not to torture my
poor graduate students so I decided to
tattoo a couple of spots on my own arm
instead and it actually worked
check it out I call these tattoos solar
freckles because they're powered by
sunshine and right now they're invisible
but as soon as I expose them to a UV
light acting as the Sun there they are
blue spots now I'm not wearing sunscreen
in this video but if I was those blue
spots would not appear and then when my
sunscreen wore off later the solar
freckles would reappear in UV light and
I would know that it was time to reapply
sunscreen so these tattoos act as a
real-time naked-eye indicator of your
skin's UV exposure and of course I think
there are lots of really cool artistic
things you could do with a color
changing tattoo like this but I hope
that it will also help us solve a big
problem in skin protection
[Music]
let me give you another example normal
human body temperature is about 97 to 99
degrees Fahrenheit and if you fall
outside of that range you need to seek
medical attention right away now the
problem is that humans can't detect our
own body temperature without a
thermometer sure you could try the old
hand on the forehead trick but there's
zero scientific evidence to back that up
so what if we could create a tattoo
label thermometer that you could access
anytime well remember how the solar
freckles used a UV sensitive dye inside
of the micro capsules of the tattoo ink
well you could also put heat sensitive
dyes inside of micro capsules and you
could make different tattoo inks that
change color at different temperatures
suppose it was 96 98 and 100 degrees
Fahrenheit if you place those inks
side-by-side now you have a temperature
scale tuned to the human body in this
video you can see the different patches
of tattoos disappearing sequentially as
the pig skin we tested them on is heated
up so if you were to place a tattoo like
this in a location that was stable to
external temperature fluctuations maybe
inside of the mouth perhaps on the back
of the lip then you'd be able to read
your body temperature any time by just
glancing at your tattoo in the mirror
amazing right another thank you
another limitation that we have as
humans is that our skin doesn't conduct
electricity and that can be a good thing
but not necessarily if you have a
biomechanical and electronic biomedical
implant like a pacemaker for example
right now if you have a pacemaker you
need surgery every 5 or 10 years to
replace the battery when it dies and
wouldn't it be nice if instead we could
simply recharge the battery through a
patch of conducting skin well if you
were to try to tackle that problem with
a tattoo the first step would be to make
a tattoo that conducts electricity so
we've been working on a conducting
tattoo ink in my lap and right now we're
able to increase the conductivity of
skin over 300 fold with our conducting
tattoo ink now we have a long way to go
before we reach the conductivity of
something like a copper wire but we're
making progress and I'm really excited
about this because I think that it could
open up a whole new world of possibility
for tattoos I envision a future where
tattoos enable us tattoo above wires and
tattoo Abul electronics enable us to
merge our technologies with our bodies
so that they feel more like extensions
of ourselves rather than external
devices so these are a few examples of
the new abilities that we can gain by
using nanotechnology to upgrade our
tattoos but this really is only the
beginning
I believe the sky is the limit for what
we can do with high-tech tattoos in the
future tattoos will not only be
beautiful they'll be functional too
thank you